on pourrait croire que c'est une
expérience comme bien d'autres à
singapour paradis culinaire
mais la viande de poulet qu'on apprête
en cuisine a été fabriqué en laboratoire
parmi les convives venus déguster cette
première mondiale un ancien chef
triplement étoilé
le produit a été conçu en laboratoire à
partir de cellules souches de poulet
prélevés par biopsie la viande est
cultivé dans un bioréacteur de 1200
litres et 14 jours plus tard seulement
quelques kg sont prêts à être consommés
selon l'approbation gouvernementale la
viande doit être frites et en format de
croquettes seulement le poulet servi
uniquement à singapour depuis déjà un an
le fruit de quatre ans de recherche en
laboratoire pour l'entreprise
californienne qu'il a élaboré
une soixantaine d'entreprises
travaillent sur de tels projets de
viande synthétique
elles disent vouloir répondre à la
demande mondiale qui devrait augmenter
de 70% d'ici 2050 la viande cultivées en
laboratoire permettrait aussi de réduire
l'empreinte écologique du secteur de
près de 80% selon certains estimé qu
il faut revoir notre système alimentaire
croit-il
la viande cultivées en laboratoire
soulève des questions éthiques
certaines entreprises utilisent des
hormones de croissance par exemple
d'autres comme i just utilise du sérum
de vaud fatale comme milieux de culture
ce qui est jugée cruelle d'un point de
vue médical ce spécialiste rappelle
qu'il faudrait plutôt changer notre
alimentation
c'est qu'on serait mieux d'avoir une
augmentation plus riche en végétaux en
protéines végétales que de se lancer
dans la viande cultivée à mon avis et ce
serait mieux pour la santé
pour le moment la production de ses
croquettes de poulet demeurent minimes
et les coûts exorbitants mais le produit
pourrait éventuellement être meilleur
marché que la viande d'élevage le chef
bruno ménard a déjà hâte après singapour
le qatar et les états unis l'entreprise
i just espère obtenir bientôt le feu
vert des autorités sanitaires il semble
inévitable que la viande cultivées en
laboratoire arrivera au canada d'ici
quelques années il suffit les clubs la
radio canada singapour